الاحتجاجات التي تشهدها الصين تفجرت اثر
حريق في مبنى السكني بمدينه
تدابير المتعلقه بمواجهه فيروس كورونا
عرقلت وصول الفرق الانقاذ في الوقت
المناسب لكن هذا الغضب الشعبيه له جذور في
حوادث عديده وقعت في الاشهر الماضيه في
ابريل لسان الماضي اندلع تحتجاجات في مركز
للحجر بمدينه شنغهاي بسبب نقص التمويل
بالغذاء وظروف الحجر الصارمه وفي شهر
سبتمبر ايلول الماضي منعت السلطات السكان
مدينه تشنجو من مغادره منازلهم بعد زلزال
ضرب المدينه مخالفه 65 قتيلا
وفي الشهر ذاته لقي 27 شخصا مسرعهم اثرا
انقلاب حافله كانت تنقلهم الى مركز للحجر
الصحي الاجباري
وفي الرابعه عشر من اكتوبر تشرين الاول
لقي الطفل مصرعها في مركز للحجر الصحي
الاجباري بعد تعرضها لوعكه صحيه وفي وقت
سابق من هذا الشهر حملت اسره في مدينه
زنجو السلطات مسؤوليه وفاه ابنتها الرضيعه
اثره اخرى وصول الاسعاف بسبب الاجراءات
المتخذه لمواجهه الوباء